uh pop Pelosi attack uh uh cops weren't
monitoring cameras during break-in uh uh
you know I'm sure you saw the story we
talked about I think briefly on Tuesday
but uh the Capitol Police has live
cameras outside Democratic house Speaker
Nancy Pelosi's home but officers were
reportedly not watching the feeds when
her husband was brutally assaulted the
Capitol Police first installed cameras
around the Pelosi residents more than
eight years ago the house speakers 24 7
security detail left San Francisco with
her when she returned to DC last week
and the Capitol Police Stopped
continuously monitoring the feeds
outside our house according to the
report police say David debepe 42 years
old broke into the house and shouted
where's Nancy he then allegedly attacked
her husband with a hammer fracture in
the skull go ahead Vinnie so okay here's
my thing and Tom we talked about this
before we went on air why is it that we
can't ask questions I can't ask a
question like you just said even little
bitty ones one like give me one like if
you were curious about this time what
would you like because you heard a bunch
of different stories what would be one
of your one of your questions gosh after
the last three years with the riots and
BLM I thought all cops had had body
cameras they have hold on that's a 100
guarantee after 30 seconds it comes on
and checks
and I just said don't and it wasn't
California one of the leading states
that all cops have their body cameras
100 here's another great question oh
you're a conspiracy theorist you're
you're already conspiracies and here's
the thing you want to shut everybody up
and shut every cons every question
asking person release the camera on the
cop so we could see exactly what
happened don't leave it up the question
because when you leave it up the
question then you have people going wait
a minute he was in his underwear the
other guy was in his underwear the glass
was broken From the Inside Out the 9-1-1
call you clearly hear the cops saying he
says it's his friend and his name is
David okay and then when he's screaming
where's Nancy I mean there could be a
bunch of different things and then
automatically they're going to put it
into January 6 and it was January 6.
there's just too many questions and I
feel bad for him and I hope he recovers
but then just a couple months ago he got
a du wine boy he's been partying
partying bro I think he's partying Pat
and to me this is my opinion he finished
his community service and was he in his
recovery did he go to his record I
remember he had community service and
Recovery classes yeah I don't know if
he's finished that take that takes no
I'm gonna be a reporter and I'm going to
take away conspiracy hey wait a minute
was her alcohol involved wasn't he going
to recovery class possession community
service because the DUI 100 he's a
conspiracy theory conspiracy theories so
I listen there's just too many questions
and going back to it it's a good point
though have the cops show them can we
ask questions I mean how do you not have
the camera on the third most you know
powerful person in America I will tell
you one person who is trending is uh
since since he used the the hammer MC
Hammer song
has been doing very well on Spotify
you mean the tell me Nancy Pelosi's
house doesn't have top-notch security
and the Father the husband is there
she's not there that's fine you cannot
tell me that because she's number two if
God forbid Biden dies and uh Kamala dies
and they both die in an accident Pelosi
is next in line she's number two not
number three you don't have cameras
there I don't believe it people are not
dumb people yeah I'm not I'm definitely
not done with that by the way of the 10
things going on in the world this is not
in my top 10 stories that I'm following
me me me okay same here I spoke let me
give a shout out to my buddy he's gonna
hear his name he's gonna flip out yeah
my he's the biggest Mega supporter one
of my best friends Joey B if you're
listening we spoke for a half hour last
night he's like I gotta tell you I want
my my conspiracy everything I'm thinking
about Paul Pelosi I'm like all right
buddy entertain me for a half hour
so he's like so I think he knew the guy
I think he let him in I'm like okay all
right that's not far-fetched security
how did he get in of course how does how
does Nancy Pelosi sounds out of security
like I'm with you okay so he's like yeah
all this is going on so I'm like what's
your conclusion they're gay lovers I'm
like no no no no what where where does
that come from they're in their
underwear I'm like are you the doctor
he was sleeping at 2 A.M and the guy got
in the house somehow so like you're
entitled a hundred percent in America to
what you think but you can't say things
that you know like as if they're facts
what you think I'm like so I'm with them
I'm like oh yeah
how do you get in there it's crazy maybe
he let him in I don't know maybe he knew
him he was a friend I don't know he's
like they claimed that he was a Maga guy
but he's a BLM guy because he how many
Maga guys are in San Francisco living in
a [ __ ] calm you know cool so The
Logical conclusion is they've been
lovers all this time it's like where did
that come from I'm not gonna lie
I messaged Pat and IG I took him a bunch
of Clips I was like Pat I even said it
they're both in their underwear he
didn't hit him until the cops showed up
and he's going where's Nancy that sounds
like a lover's quarrel yeah and he's
like where is that [ __ ] that sounds
like what I I said that's my guy Joey
one question I go the guy's 80 something
years old find me one other story he's
been in the public eye for 50 years one
other gay lover story he's like that
there's nothing out there I'm like
really so this is what's happening I
mean he's kept it for a long time right
one week before midterms yeah Nancy's
out of town boom now's my chance come on
bro so if you like this clip and you
want to watch another one click right
here and if you want to watch the entire
podcast click right here
foreign